SPEAKER: In this
video, we'll talk
about what happens when a
user decides to activate
a subscription in your app.
When your app starts,
call startConnection
in the Google Play
billing library.
Once the connection
is complete, you
will also need to call
queryPurchases in order
to handle existing purchases.
Make sure to override
onPurchasesUpdated in order
to handle any future
purchases that complete
while your app is open.
Once the connection
is properly set up,
launch the billing flow in the
Google Play Billing Library
to start the new
subscription purchase.
After the user
completes the purchase,
Google Play will send a
purchase token and order ID back
to your app via
onPurchasedUpdated.
The purchase token represents
the user's active entitlement
to a product or service
your app provides,
and the order ID serves as
a receipt for the user's
transaction with Google.
Before the user's
subscription can be activated,
your app sends
this purchase token
to your server for
verification and registration.
Once your server receives
the purchase token,
it will first send
the token to be
verified by Google through
Google Play Developer API.
The API call will
either succeed or fail.
If it fails, then the
token is not valid.
If it succeeds, that
means the token is valid,
and you should keep track of
the information in the response.
This purchase information is
then stored on the server,
and the server lets the app
know that the subscription is
activated.
You can now grant the user
the appropriate access
to your product or services.
For more information,
visit the link onscreen,
or check out our
other videos here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]